[Music]
my name is Ben Chong I'm a product
manager at Google and as a product
manager I need to serve expectations
with you all my customers
I guess there's absolutely no speaker
notes here nothing so all the bad jokes
are all my fault okay all right
so I'm gonna talk to you about moving
your data to cloud it's actually easier
than you think hopefully by the end of
this you will believe so
oops okay I so how many of you knew that
this was googles mission all right about
half maybe so like our mission is to
make all the world's information easily
accessible right and useful
there's same infrastructure there we are
using it's not available to you right
through Google cloud we are basically
using the same platform same
applications making it available as part
of the cloud platform products suite
and it allows you to meet your company's
data available very accessible useful
get value of them so here's what you can
do right with your data or you can do
run some analytics run some machine
learning models on it create new
services new products all of your data
your existing data we can move your
applications to the cloud from data
center and kind of like make it more
useable serve content from cloud and
also you can just store data on cloud
for the long term we have customers
trying to saw data or playing the store
data in cloud for next 99 years okay but
all these things is possible only if you
can get all your data today most of the
data in today's world is in data center
not in cloud and you realize that is
actually very hard to move data right
like and one reason why you're here that
you're thinking that is really difficult
because I I have a lot of data I have
very little bandwidth there's a lot of
paperwork and great tape I have to go to
in order to get like new network
connectivity how many of you remember
seeing as part of the intro slide showed
the note about Evernote yeah so Evernote
took about seven months to move a few
petabytes of data there's a pretty large
team of people doing that right so
they're basically roll their own
applications with the GCS api's so it's
kind of tough right even with the kind
of bandwidth that they had so how you
get your data to Google Cloud depends on
the kind of data that you have and the
kind of data sources the way we look at
the world today is unstructured data
which are files stuff right on object
object or NAND storage devices in your
data center or structured data and
generally databases so the stuff we're
going to talk about unstructured data
and for this I my colleague ash who will
cover it
thanks man thank you for joining us this
afternoon my name is Ashe Ahluwalia and
I'm a product manager that works on
large data moves over the network
primarily unstructured data so one of
the first questions that or first couple
of questions you'll need to answer when
doing a large unstructured data move are
one how much data are you looking to
move and two how much bandwidth do you
have to move it so just to get a sense
of how where people land on the spectrum
in the room today how many folks here
have a connection to the Google cloud
that is faster than ten gigabits per
second faster than 10 Gbps by show of
hands okay a couple of folks how many
folks have a connection speed that is
slower than one gigabit per second to
Google cloud okay a couple of other
folks how many people have no idea how
fast their connection is to the Google
cloud okay like 80 percent of you so you
now know one of the questions that
you're gonna have to go answer after
hearing this talk so depending on where
you are on this spectrum your transport
can take anywhere from seconds or
minutes to days or even weeks so it's
important to understand the answer to
these two questions before you start
doing a large unstructured data move now
this is a pretty complicated graphic so
let me boil it down a little bit we can
keep the y axis is how much data you're
moving and on the x axis instead of
bandwidth let's come up with an easier
concept to grasp you can think of this
data by how far away it is from GCP so
if you have data that is sitting already
inside of GCP or it's in another public
cloud vendor like AWS there's pretty
high bandwidth connections between those
public cloud vendors and so even a
moderately large data set can be moved
pretty quickly so in that sense the data
is pretty close to GCP now you can think
one step further away let's say you have
an on-prem data center with a typical
public connection speed to the public
internet and then you can even have
further afield data centers that are in
remote locations or have limited or no
event no connection to the Internet
in which case even a small data move is
going to take a lot of time in that
sense it's far from GCP so what we'll do
today is kind of walk through products
on different ends of this spectrum and
how I can use them for you data move so
we'll start with data that is close to
GCP with a product called the cloud
storage transfer service this product is
explicitly designed to move data from
public cloud to GCP whether that is
within GCP from one region to another or
from another public cloud like AWS to
GCP some pretty common use cases for
this include people that are archiving
or saving a backup copy to GCS as part
of their multi cloud strategy some folks
pull data from other public clouds into
Google Cloud for analysis in a tool like
bigquery and then finally some folks use
this tool to move data between GCS
regions as part of their daily
operations now in addition to pulling
data from s3 and GCS as I've talked
about the cloud storage transfer service
can also pull data from any publicly any
data that is publicly addressable on the
internet via HTTP in addition it
supports a one-time transfer or repeated
sink and is also available in all
regions where GCS operates today so
let's do a little bit of a walk through
of what this service looks like if you
actually went to use it so to find it
you would go into the cloud console and
under Google Cloud storage there would
be an option called transfer and if you
clicked on that you would see a summary
of all the transfers that are running
and are done and you'd also have the
opportunity to start a transfer to start
a transfer basically it involves three
steps first identify the data that you
want to move second tell us where you
want to move it and thirdly tell us when
you want to move it it's just that
simple
so walk through an example here first
identify the data you want to move so
here hopefully you guys can see this
I'll point it out to you you can pick an
Amazon s3 buckets and give us the
credentials that we need to list objects
and pull data from that bucket and then
you can tell us what prefixes to include
or exclude and you can also use s3
metadata to choose what objects to pull
over
for instance basing your poll on last
modified time so if you want to only
pull objects from s3 that have been
modified in the last week you can do
that the second step is to figure out
where to move this data and to do that
you can pick essentially any GCS bucket
and we support all GCS storage classes
finally you have to tell us when you
want to move it
now you basically to two options here
one is to just move it right now or you
can schedule a daily sync at a time of
your choosing so for instance if you
have a workload on AWS that writes new
objects to s3 every day you can schedule
a transfer job to run every night at
midnight to sync those over to GCS so
that's a little bit about the cloud
storage transfer service now the next
step on this larger graphic here is if
you have a presence in a Colo org an
on-premise data center that has good
connectivity the Internet in that case
we offer a product called gsutil that
you can use to push your data to GCS
gsutil
is a command-line utility that is
specifically designed to help you push
data from a data center that you are
operating into GCP and because it's a
command-line utility you can use it for
your manual workflows or as part of a
script you can also run it in a
background process where it's constantly
syncing files and directories to a GCS
bucket of your choosing now in addition
to the sync and copy options we talked
about gsutil also operates in a stream
mode so if you have a process that's
long-running and outputs data
periodically you can pipe that output to
gsutil
and it will push it along to GCS GCS has
GCS util has a lot of options I'm not
going to go through all of them but I'll
highlight a couple it automatically
retries if it encounters ephemeral
Network errors or errors from GCS it
also supports customer managed and
customer supplied encryption keys and
finally it object it obeys the object
versioning semantics that are typical of
most GCS clients
so let's talk a little bit about some of
the questions that come up when people
use gsutil the first one is how do I
move my data quickly so there are a
couple of features that gsutil has to
help you do this the first is using
multi-threading so you can use the - am
flag to ensure that the gsutil process
is running multiple threads which are
pulling all of your files in parallel
and pushing them to GCS now if that's
not fast enough to fill up your
bandwidth to DCP you can also split up
and run gsutil on multiple hosts and by
doing so move your data in parallel
across multiple gsutil processes and use
up more of your bandwidth and I do that
one the important thing to note is that
you'll have to manually partition your
data in advance so that none of these
separate gsutil processes are stomping
on one another now let's say you did
that one of the problems you may
encounter especially if you're moving a
large set of files is that there's one
file and one one gsutil thread and one
process moving it so if you have a
really large file like a hundred
gigabyte file you might sit there
waiting for that thread to move byte by
byte for that really large file and it
just takes too long so to address that
situation juice util has a feature
called parallel composite uploads what
it does is it basically takes large
files breaks them into chunks and moves
all of those chunks simultaneously to
GCS once they arrive at GCS those chunks
are now composited into a single GCS
object it does require a little bit of
setup you have to set some environment
variables and compile of library for CRC
mod for the host where GS util is
installed in addition it is important to
note that if you are using certain
storage classes for GCS it does incur
additional cost as these composite
pieces are put together
so a couple of other assorted questions
that come up when people are using GS
util the first is how do I control how
much bandwidth it's using for instance
if I already have workloads in my data
center
I don't want GS util to use up all the
bandwidth that those workloads need to
use so how do I stop that unfortunately
today GS utila does not have native
support for bandwidth throttling but you
can use tools like trickle or your
network network administration controls
to control how much bandwidth gcutil
uses another question that comes up is
how do I preserve my metadata especially
if I'm trying to do use GCS or GS util
to make a backup of my data onto GCS to
do that you can use the dash P option
which preserve takes your file metadata
your POSIX file metadata and puts it
into the metadata of the GCS objects as
you copy them over
finally some folks are concerned about
overwriting data that already exists in
the GCS bucket if you're concerned about
that you can use the - an option which
ensures that you do not clobber any data
that already exists so these are a
couple of little tools and tricks that
you can use with gsutil there's actually
a lot more to read and understand before
we become an expert on this so before I
hand it back to Ben I just want to
highlight three things that I covered
off on today one whenever you're doing a
large transfer think about how much data
you need to move and how much bandwidth
you have to move it secondly take a look
at some of the features we walk through
today and some of our extensive
documentation on these two products to
figure out how which features make the
most sense for the data you're trying to
move and thirdly and most importantly in
my opinion whenever you're doing a large
transfer always start with a small
sample of the data that you intend to
move so you understand what features
make sense for you how much it's going
to cost and how long it's going to take
with that let me hand it back to Ben to
talk about the farthest end of the
spectrum when you have a remote data
center with limited bandwidth or no
connection to the Internet at all thanks
thanks ash
all right so what if you are in a
situation where you have very little
bandwidth or even if you have been with
a lot of it sticking up by other
workloads or you're in a situation where
there's no network at all right so this
is what we call offline transfers so for
that we have Google transfer points
right this is the the first hardware
product at Google Cloud the shipping how
many of you have been to Moscone West
and seen it in person just less than a
handful so we actually have a real
appliance out more skinny West in a
showcase floor that you can actually
touch it's a real appliance it has all
sixty drives in it so this is a high
capacity storage server that we ship to
customers and the idea is that you will
load your data onto the plan ship it
back to us we uploaded for you I want to
focus on the use cases right because
there is you know when we talk to
customers a lot of customers start
thinking about interconnect and so and
so forth or upgrading your network
bandwidth and we know that there's a
complicated process right there's the
budget there is availability and so and
so forth it's not a lot of eyes peas
want you to come in to a two-year period
and then your CIO comes to you and say
hey I want to try out these machine
learning stuff but I do not want to
invest in you know high bandwidth
networks so what what do you do right we
have had good relatively good customer
success where we should be a TA 100
which is the hungry terabyte appliance
they load it with 40 to 70 terabytes of
the other ship it back to us and then
with that amount of data they can
actually run a pretty good machine
learning modeling exercise right and
after that they're happy enough that
they sign on with us for a long term so
this is really good for for pocs you are
not blocked by the availability of
network in the connect all the kind of
conversations with ISPs another use case
is where customers decide that look
to end-of-life their on-prem storage
right and then they want to move all
that data to clout this is really good
for that so we we ship them this like
the big one that you see there load it
with all the data I should be back to us
and we saw in GCS generally : on your
line for the long term how many of you
have seen our blog where we talk about
the Schmidt Ocean Institute you know so
believe it or not like there are data
centers on ships right so this customer
of ours we go on a cruise for about a
month or so actually take the smaller
appliance and their racket in the ship
there's actually data center in the ship
the calling all the data when and while
they're collecting the other days they
are singing into the appliance so once
they reach port they ship it back to us
and then we load it to GCS and then they
share with the rest of the researchers
right worldwide and then we have
customers and this is a last use case
for monthly longer batches of data so we
have customers we'd also like your poor
networks or insufficient but networks
and then use this for that now transfer
appliance is available in the u.s. today
right we're generally available we
announced at about month ago we are
studying a pilot program in the EU size
unit European Union for you so like how
many European customers are they here
alright cool so like feel free to reach
back out to me or you can sign up with
the link here we reach back out to you
and get you started
once we kick off that process and it's
gonna be in a couple weeks
all right so like quick summary of the
onboarding process you go to Pantheon
clunk sorry
cloud console to you guys request an
appliance we send it to you you
configure it set it up fill it with data
ship it back to us we do the painful
stuff of uploading data for you and then
the last step you decrypt your data and
move it to the location or the storage
class that you you want
your data to resign in the long term and
then the appliance after the data has
been uploaded we wipe it securely common
questions include ok what do you do
right the on wiping we wipe we
repartition the hard drives reformat the
hard drives
reinstall the OS in case our customers
decide to install some application on it
because we have heard oh you're running
Linux on it
ok I'm gonna install some some tools but
no no no so we reinstall the OS to
reinstall the application and then get
it ready for the next customer so
essentially the next customer will get a
new appliance alright so I'm gonna walk
through like what ash did the overall
appliance experience there you can see
in cloud console if you go to the
storage tab there's option now for
transfer lines fill up the form here
it's good to know like how much data you
want to move and please don't submit
multiple times because we process all
these things manually so it's kind of
fun to see you like you know some
customers if I hit submit more often
we'll get more more appliances will work
with you there's actually a person at
the end of this so we'll work with you
to ship you the right appliances and
again there's another person there's a
person at the end on this so you know
we'll work with you right so it's not a
machine that is going to shut you down
and I don't see this kind of thing it's
a real person and we'll make sure that
you you get the best support you that
you need this is a picture of the back
of the appliance and you can see the
real thing in Moscone West you can see
there is the Senate power supply
connectors we have fiber optic ports
here for then we will supply the
transceivers so you need transceivers
there are four copper ethernet ports now
why do we have for this allows you to do
network aggregation right so you can run
at a throughput of 40 gigs per second
right up to put so that networking
itself is no longer the the limiting
factor for you to capture they're down
to the appliance and we have customers
where the internal networks are in one
gig by running it at four at a time we
are able to achieve four gigabits per
second is just not too bad
and allows them to capture data quickly
enough this is where we talk about
encryption so the data is encrypted in
transit we use aes-256 there's no phone
home at all the appliance is completely
disconnected from Google Cloud the key
is generated by you guys right so you as
part of this setting setup you type in
your or create a password pass phrase
that's used to generate the key the
encryption key is starting ramen on the
appliance so we are capturing data you
know the key is being used once you
power off the appliance will ship it
back to us the key is gone when you read
what were call rehydrate which is called
a decrypting the data that is done
within your project so that's and we
don't have access to it all right so we
probably web-based UI you connect to the
appliance using a web browser today we
support Chrome don't ask me why and you
can see the job status the available
physical capacity as well as they will
use it so you know something is
happening there we offer a few capture
options so the first two options let us
capture utility in Windows capture
utility are for situations where you
need to do a fair amount of
authentication to access your data
sources right in that situation you will
have other windows workstation or Linux
workstation sitting between your data
source and the transfer appliance and
the capture utility will read data from
the data source and push it to the
transfer appliance mount NFS share is
essentially where the appliance is able
to mount or where you allow the
appliance to mount your data sources and
you will pull the data from the data
source and the last option there which
is new and which is pretty popular
because this is an easy concept is where
the appliance itself can be configured
to be an ass box right so you can mount
it through NFS and just copy your rsync
data to it it's very easy
easy thing to do them so again this is a
screenshot that shows a couple of
options in progress so the first option
there you can see NFS client is where
the appliance is acting as an NFS client
reading data from an sbox
and the second option there is that we
have exposed part of the appliance as an
NFS share alright so once you have
captured data onto the appliance you
ship it to us this is actually the box
that you see in Muscatine west and we
upload it to a Google bucket so the
final step is rehydration that's where
you will run a VM a GC v m in your GC p
project this way you will decrypt the
data and move it to the GCP bucket GCS
bucket off of your choice in the region
on your choice so we don't control where
you move your data for example you can
decide to you have data in the US you
want to move it to a European bucket you
can still run the appliance process and
then when you decrypt the the data it
can be sawn into the GCS bucket in
Europe I mean this is a screenshot of
the UI with the rehydration jobs running
and finally when all is said and done we
provide a summary dialog that tells you
how much data was transferred number of
files will highlight failures like you
know sometimes files on this because I
did a deleted while being captured or
there are some integrity failures
integrity is where we do a checksum
right so the sauce fall destination file
we do crc32 and will tell you if a bit
has been flipped
so we are working with a bunch of
partners for transfer appliance so
here's one use case where you're using
con volt to backup your data right but
the first initial coppers of backup data
can be so large then it's not feasible
to transfer it over the network so user
transfer appliance as a backup target
backup to transfer appliance we upload
their initial a backup corpus into a GCS
bucket and then you will do the deltas
over the network
so we're working with our partner
cohesive or very similar use case as
well alright so this is kind of like a
summary of our own solutions for data
transfers partner solutions so Google is
very partner friendly for online data
transfers we have plan options from
chabela aspera bit speed and comm price
and for offering options like if you
have two live data that's you know too
little data for just two appliance
because this one supplies about hundred
terabytes what if you have about five
terabytes of data you can work with Iron
Mountain to ship the drives to them or a
lot of customers have data already
storing hard drives they can ship the
hard drives to Iron Mountain as well and
this is another interesting use case
where if you were to have active data
sets that are changing all the time you
may not want to freeze the data sets all
your workflow just because you want to
move data to true transfer plans or
through other means so is out our story
chickens
basically take a snapshot of data moving
to a cloud and then sync at the back end
all right so this is a summary of types
of options for unstructured data so
let's talk about structured data index
this Nick section section is very very
quick section we will cover databases
the other Lake bigquery and this is
basically going to just give you an idea
of what's available I'm not gonna go
into too much depth here and you see a
lot of logos flow by in and that's
because a lot of it is true patent
solutions so database migration what we
are saying here is that it's not just
about the data right there's a few
things you need to think about the
migration of the data and schema is just
one of it database assessment data
discovery the migration surrenders the
app logic migration because no database
lives by itself we're just going to
cover data discovery and data schema
migration here this is a redirection
slide so where you can do data discovery
informatica that's who we are partnering
with that you have a session after this
where they will cover what they can do
here right so for point their discovery
is finding out what you have we find
that since the the son of trout you find
a lot of you know teams in IT
departments they can start cloud
products or clump projects and the CIO
or the rest of the company may known may
not know what's out there so the idea
here is if I what you have so you can
current figure out what you need to do
when to migrate over here we talk about
data schema migration right to spanner
and cloud sequel so we again we have a
bunch of partners they can migrate data
and the schemas from different sources
out there
now if you are looking at creating a
data Lake on GCP GCS with data proc the
session up there is over but we all the
sessions are videotape so you guys can
can watch that online so again we have
partners that you helped me move data
from either HDFS or other cloud object
storage to - GCS for use with data proc
bigquery is again you know a bunch of
third party logos here again this so
highlight that Google is actively
partnering with a lot of other companies
to to provide solutions to our customers
right as you think about leveraging
clouds as you think about doing a lift
and shift to cloud for existing
workloads and finally this is a Google
product bigquery a data transfer service
so a lot of marketers are using write
the products you see on the left here
for marketing campaigns and so on and
bigquery is a great tool to figure out
like what customers are actually doing
well how are they are they clicking how
are they reacting with the interacting
with the ads are they actually falling
through and and because you have
different data sources bigquery is a
good way of combining all of them
joining the data sets and getting some
intelligence of it alright so that's the
end of the presentation
[Music]